I went to rehab I was there for over a
month I went back in November I did it
because I I had to you know for for uh
my addiction and all that [__] and I I
need to be present and but my God it was
a trauma-based thing that I uh I went to
and um
one of the best in the world and holy
[__] [__] man
really uh
the work that they do there is
absolutely amazing I met so many great
people dude a lot of those guys in there
um obviously like you know you don't
share names and [__] but like my God
they were just like the the most
uh to make lifelong friends at 42 and
already know about it
like a weekend just like these are these
are my people it's hilarious too like
because like when you're when you're an
addict you're also yourself do you know
what I'm talking about you're you're
also yourself
so
what I went in as myself what I thought
right and and like you're like all right
I'm gonna go to this thing now I have an
unbelievable amount of fear in my life
I have an unbelievable amount of fear in
my life
ever since I was a little kid
just every second in my head is
something my you know someone's gonna
abduct my parents somebody's gonna kill
my dad somebody's gonna poison me right
just been there from as early as I can
remember did not sleep through the night
in my bed until I was maybe
13 like I would run into my parents like
just being honest with you guys like
running my parents room my dad would
come and be like you gotta go to sleep
whatever dude just terrified of
everything and
um
you go in with the tapes that play in
your head you know of
I got this but I also secretly don't
have this because I'm scared because
like I'm lonely I think I'm not worthy
of love and like
whatever it is and I think I'm not uh
uh important
do I matter you know the real the
negative core beliefs that you have of
yourself and you go in and you think uh
but I'm I'm me I'm different I'm you
know that whole that that's poison to
think that you're different or above it
all or whatever the [__] it is but you
walk in that way and then when you walk
in with that fear me me I should say me
when I walk in with that fear and that
all that compartmentalization and all
that stuff that I've been working with
and working on for 42 years to build my
[__] walls up
um
you just walk in and you see the other
dudes who just they just they you know
what they look like
people
they're just people they're people that
you might see
you know where somewhere
somewhere somewhere on the way somewhere
or maybe at the place
right
or on the news somewhere talking about
some [__] you know parade that
they're yeah I'm really happy about that
that guy is there
and some people look
cool some people look not cool some
people look fashionable not fashionable
some people look sad some people are
joking around and you walk in and you
just go I you have this I had this
thought where I was just I walked in and
I was just like oh
I'm like this
right you walk in with all that baggage
and then
you will see everyone else you see a guy
with like a a [__] um uh uh a Beijing
soccer team jersey on
and then a tall guy from Kenya who's
like six foot 19.
with Patagonia on and you're like oh
ah
I'm like this though
and those were my [__] people
dude
I didn't want to well I don't know if I
didn't want to talk about it but it's
just it just went on it's it's what's
happening in my life and
it's so important to me you know
and I and I and I love those guys and
and and the therapy there dude was
I mean
it was like
it was like the therapists take their
heart out put it on the front of their
boots
and kick in the [__] teeth for hours
a day
that's what it's like
they take their heart they take their
blood they take their tears from
whatever they've been working with
because a lot of them were addicts too
or our addicts and they just take their
heart out you go you sit in a chair they
put their heart on the [__] tip of
their Boot and they just go sit tight
and [__] just
just kick in the goddamn teeth and it is
the most
painful beautiful thing
and it's necessary and it's hard yeah it
just it's something I should have done a
long time ago and I and I didn't and uh
I did
and uh
I I I I I can't
express enough that if you are
an addict or whatever it is even if you
think you got it
you know what I'm talking about even if
you think I got this or even if you've
had it it's so hard to make
um
it's so hard to make
a a it a priority
Mental Health
um
and doing it
moving life you know to do it
for me it's just it was too important
man like
I I
know I come on here I'm this funny guy
but like you know
like I I get these [__]
you know suicidal ideation and [__] like
that and it's just I
the
you have to keep that [__] in check and
I [__] I cry on [__] podcast all
the goddamn time but
whatever
um so you have to get
you have it's just such a good idea man
and and it was so cool to hear the
therapists and how much they care about
you and they they keep in touch with me
now for [__] sake
um
you know I heard that the guys in there
miss me now
so
crazy crazy crazy crazy
crazy crazy
[Music]